all right for people joining a live
stream this is a brainstorming
discussion about a very old issue which
is how best to format polynomials like
this we say x squared minus one there
and in standard form in standard form
that comes out as minus one plus x
squared and the question is are we
optimizing what we do for multivariate
polynomials in traditional form so does
Roger or Michael want to say something
about that
you
I hope the hell yes I'm here but no okay
great
why did it come up now can I ask what
the motivation is for a bunch of
possible issues yeah a bunch of cases
that I saw that looked really ugly
I actually don't remember is the real
answer um why why it came up right I
mean I think this has been something
which has been planned to be discussed
for months so my guess was WolframAlpha
notebooks but not definitely not okay so
what level I can say about this is that
like we have in traditional form we have
dedicated code for ordering polynomials
and in fact there that was worked on
like leaked by you with Maxime for
version 7 and there's a variable thing
which controls whether or not to use it
and there are cases where we disable it
because it's and it's potentially quite
slow and so if speed is very important
we might disable it before specific when
typesetting certain expressions believe
it's form backtick dollar use well is it
the case I mean conceivably this is one
of these there isn't a problem we
shouldn't worry about it I mean is that
uh I mean I think this is always very
frustrating to me the fact that the
standard form formats that way but I
guess there's nothing we can really do
about that I mean do we think this is
right yes it is right you don't know yes
what would each I said you don't want to
mess that up with standard form in this
particular way because of compatibility
oh because it's it's better the way it
is it's better the way it is it
shouldn't visually more or less reflect
the input form with respect to order
lists well I understand it but but why
is the input form why is order why is
the ordering criterion putting minus one
before x squared well it's part of the
internal canonical or during which in
turn is very important for
adding and multiplying the internals of
plus and times I mean yeah maybe we
could have two different versions of
that one for output formatting and no no
I'm not suggesting I'm asking you the
question the fact that this comes out in
this order I see you're saying
algorithmic play it's a nautical ization
is important internally because that's
where we collect constant parts for
example saying that the canonicalization
critically depends on the fact that the
terms of what x to the zero come first
and so under that right yes my
recollection you know there's this code
acumen amused in both plus and times to
get constant parts and it really does
want to see that stuff first in the
ordering there's a lot of times in plus
internal code that does rely on that
emerges a frowny amygdala right yeah I
mean the advantage of this canonical
ordering zeroth order term is first was
as opposed you could say it's always
last but it's always first
well there I guess I there is in plus
and times there's an internal code that
relies on that so we would have to have
two different versions of ordering if we
were going to have it format differently
by default what do you buy two different
versions of order if you mean me we
can't mess with the internal code I'm
not sure could you mute yourself please
um okay so I mean to pee
agree that that's an unfortunate
ordering for display I'm not convinced
one way or the other really I mean no
human would like that like you know no
human would say that polynomial in that
order you usually want to see the top
degree going down for power series it's
the opposite I'm not convinced one way
or the other if it didn't start with a
minus sign you probably wouldn't
wouldn't worry about it okay format I
never heard of it how old is it
years old probably I have this vague
recollection Robby Peleus worked on
something like that probably going back
to when he was in tech support Wow okay
what does it do well apparently nothing
in this case but it does somehow reorder
things and they know it's used all over
the Alpha codebase I know I can't answer
very specifically what it does I thought
that we ordered things you just look at
the code and see what isn't it inside
traditions been traditional for me time
traditional form does go degree first I
thought it does we can see that here
okay yeah right
um alright I have another question if we
looked at the just the in the wild
literature of all the polynomials and
expressions and so on the people of hand
formatted do we know what we would see
and you know did we do that for version
7 I don't know 4 to get to this ordering
I mean you would
right you were the one that that was
involved in that yeah well I don't I
don't know let me see I can look at my
archives um so you said Maxine was the
person who was some right okay so there
is you need to send an option so if you
do polynomial form of that and then add
a traditional option traditional order
goes to true then it's that okay in turn
ste traditional order okay there we go
okay interesting okay so in other words
we could conceivably have this rapper
I mean independent of traditional form
which does a million other things in
terms of formatting this is a rapper
that would give us that that is that
just to display form yeah it should be
yes okay but it's not okay but it's not
an actual transform so doesn't strip
itself okay so there's a lot of activity
I see in my archive in 2006 on
traditional form do you think that's the
period of time when was version 7 late
oh six or seven
okay
um
[Music]
you
okay so I'm looking at looks like there
was a lot of activity in Oh around this
that's when 80s came out came out
November Oh 8 which version 7 okay
yeah I was mistaken 17 out in late Oh 8
and then the point releases were a no 9
okay
Wow okay so this traditional for
tooltips okay so there's a bunch of
stuff here um let me just look up
polynomials
a lot of love commits associated with
this um
you
you
okay well I'm seeing a bunch of
notebooks from design reviews
tooltips um
okay well I don't know I'm sure it's
here in this archive but not so easy to
pick up well my question is if we were
to get a bunch of polynomials from you
know random papers and so on what would
be find in terms of the ordering that we
would see lots of different things so
for instance hmm if it's you know for
various domains like a commutative
algebra zone probably would be in an
order which is known as a term order
like what we use for Grabner bases if
it's in distributed form you would find
if someone uses sort of a recursive
style algorithm that effectively do one
dimension at a time it would probably
not be distributed at all it would be
univariate with coefficients that are
themselves polynomials
you know univariate all the way down for
instance and you can have mixtures of
that you can have factored forms you can
have yeah you would often find them
elided because they tend to be big
you
so there's a lot of things to do but the
way this specific thing at you know
right I by the way I noticed Sondra on
livestream agreeing with my issue that
you know when you start showing people
our product doing Matthew things this
always strikes them as odd I mean it's
there's always a hiccup explaining that
Michael do you have any comments on this
I mean in WolframAlpha we don't do this
right and more falafel we would do it
the other way around
I'm not mistaken I feel like if you
really use the program to do
calculations defected what you see is in
agreement with the canonical or all
outweighs any potential also
disadvantage using traditional form we
do order things you know one question I
would raise is do we have complaints
about traditional form whereas it just
not flexible enough or not visible
enough I think we have we have implicit
complaints about standard form that I'm
with Michael I wouldn't mess with it and
the Atari I think said that also well ok
is there any Michael do we have any
great cache of formulas that people that
Tim exists out there that have typed in
in a particular order and things
probably the void for my phone is the
best what we have because for the input
interpretation be resourced although
they came in you know someone is
complaining on our live stream that
polynomials look much worse than in lay
tech do they but they take doesn't
really old oh yeah right I don't think
that that's necessarily an ordering
issue what we might want to get
confirmation from the person who
commented about that but I think it's
latex formatting somehow it looks a bit
different on the printed page I think
then then ours then I don't know if
that's the issue being raised here or
not it would be good if we could get
clarification I think general my
understanding is that the general
complains about that when you're
comparing with tech is that you know the
relative sizing of the superscripts and
placement that's what I was thinking
this might refer to that's why I say we
should get try to get some clarification
on that issue this person on a live
stream is suggesting Ethan black 86 is
suggesting we could run X eel a tech
layout engine for improved cliffs I
don't know what that is but um can we
can I easily pull up something where I
can render this I mean the the joke back
in the day was Don Knuth when we were
first developing tech forum and so on
had this whole prize for if anybody can
find a bug in tech they get you know
some number of dollars by that point but
the fact was as soon as we started
machine generating things we just found
bugs all over the place um nobody had
really tried machine generating stuff so
if we take this for example
and can we easily render this is there
an obvious way to render this in tech
for me do we have our new um rendering
system
anybody want to comment on that I mean
we have this new mechanism in the cloud
at least for being able to enter a tech
in text cells which is kind of cool
I don't think that exists let me see if
there's a development cloud I can go to
which would have that otherwise you can
go to quit quit later comm sounds
relevant um well let's see we could do
it in our own cloud or let's go ahead
and do that let's go to quick lay tech
dot-com okay enter the code can I just
put this in here no I have to do a
beginning a line whatever it is do I
have to do a begin end
just copy it into the current formulas
okay there we go and we're comparing
that with okay so let's get that as a
bitmap oops well that looks like latex
for sure how to compare it with this
okay I think it's a different font I
don't know I mean some people just plain
like the tech font better and you see
that the spacing is somewhat tighter
between the X to the 9th Y and so on
right and even between the leading
coefficient and the X yeah we could
presumably adjust that here if we wanted
to I mean we can I mean the issue that
we have is let's imagine that what we
did here was some and let's see what
happens if I do that let's say um xx x
plus YY y to the sixth let's say okay
and let's say traditional form of that I
mean the problem is that we are setting
ourselves up for a much more elaborate
everyone into singular dietetics issues
what do you mean I mean I think that was
quite reasonable what it did there okay
so now it goes to that so let's see what
happens over here I don't know I mean
yes it is tighter right so I think
that's probably what most people are
responding to and also I would also say
I don't think that like logic is using
the default tech even that or it's
coming in the over
zooom but it's not what I'm seeing me
when I locally run honest-to-goodness la
tech and view it and the DVI viewer okay
I know right but I certainly see is the
much tighter spacing and maybe the
numbers the superscripts aren't quite as
scrunched as you see I mean I have to
say I don't consider ours bad and I
think I like the consistency of the fact
that you know there's this space for
multiplication which occurs everywhere
else um okay well look maybe the
conclusion of this meeting is that
there's nothing dramatic we need to do
here um and you know I kind of had this
idea that perhaps we should be looking
at you know natural math from the wild
to get an idea of what was happening out
there but I I guess I'm not it is the
case actually I mean one thing I'm not
sure why we're not doing is we certainly
can bring back
I mean
that's happening in the cloud will allow
ones who simply render stuff as tech and
that is sort of an experiment and it
might be moved to the desktop as well
for people who are trying sorry that
tech look would be so nice if we could
get that you know from PDFs for example
what you know books converting notebooks
to PDF using perhaps some tech
intermediary to get that that lower look
which slows this one yes as opposed to
the traditional form traditional forms
not bad but that lower ones a lot better
okay well if you really think that we
should explore this because it's
certainly you know in modern times it's
certainly doable wasn't tool so so I
think that there is a set of
optimizations for us to do on spacing
and if John Folse was here he would
degree we even had a meeting in our tech
conference couple years ago focusing on
typesetting issues and maybe some people
down the stream but part of that
workgroup disambiguate checkers and te
CH conference but yes yes right he had
some follow-up discussion in which I
think the consensus was Jason Harris for
the just front end spacing what could
that happen and I I'm not sure I'm not
sure if it just was waiting on any light
or if like never came up with a formal
spec I'm not sure what happened to that
but well it's possible I was waiting to
be light which would have delayed it for
five years so but I think that there are
sort of benchmark formulas that we can
use and we can use wider things to but
you have to kind of you have to live
initially and then you can sort of go
white or after that but that's that's
what I think you know how do we do on
this kind of formula spacing wise and
all of that would sort of pop out and
some of that was brought up by that
group that met may be solicited input
how long ago was that maybe two years
well it's probably so we should ask
Jason this is some
but
the man who is here from project
management right can can you get um come
can you ask Jason Harris offline about
this please yeah sure yeah Jason is at
least last I knew Jason was in New
Zealand so that would not be a good time
to reach him
yeah I understand that's why I didn't
suggest trying to reach him right the
second I was suggesting offline just
clarifying that for the person okay
right um and I think that that would be
a very useful exercise because you know
I think that when I look at formulas
it's generally okay but a lot of things
are a little bit off
it wasn't tuned you know there's a round
of tuning that needs to be done well it
was tuned to 25 years ago but but the
world you know things may have changed
since then and the goals may have
changed slightly but I think also um the
things that have changed new fonts have
come in so you know little you know
there might be some things that we're
not quite retuned as we've changed the
fonts that the true we have changed the
fonts right you know it came out in 96
this typesetting engine that we have
right right um and
you know yes the other issue which is
which is still unsolved is formulas that
don't mean anything which are easy to
enter in tech and you can certainly
enter them in our you know but it
doesn't it's not particularly useful to
enter them in you know our notebooks I
use it all the time what formulas that
don't mean anything
yeah lots of it what do you mean I mean
that so but but you have to have things
like you know matched operators and so
on because it's pausing things right I
mean if I say oh no if I just want an
invite no no I understand that but if I
say something like you know X circle x
yeah but you're using input now I'm
saying an in line formula in text
I'm not interpreting them no I
understand but if I say X times I'll get
that you know so let's say this is in
text and now I make an inline cell I
don't and I put that in there yeah oh
and it works just fine
exactly I do it all the time
want to use them as input they had
better parts yeah but but okay but but
so what happens to the spacing rules for
example the spacing rules for operators
but when you use something that's not
classified as an operator you're you
kind of have to deal with it yourself
which you have to do in tech by the way
yes Oh they've chapters on the you know
the fine points of spacing no I
understand that but I mean if I say here
so right away so we use traditional form
you know like in examples and other
things and in notes in you know a lot in
our own documentation and one of my big
grumbles with with a traditional form
when we use it there is that it want to
do what you did now we never want to
stack things in line that's a bad way
to do things in line because things get
so small you can't read it yes you know
so that's always something that you have
to adjust and you have to teach
everybody how to adjust and sometimes
ordering rules but it's not just a
polynomial ordering rules it's a
miscellaneous it's sort of everything
well okay but you're saying the default
there I mean clearly if I have a large
enough expression if I say um you know
some well here let me do some giant
number let's say you know a hundred
factorial divided by I have to do
something which won't cancel let's say
like that right I'll get this whereas if
I do you know something like this it'll
do that right and you're saying that in
line you would not like it to stack even
in that case that's also something
that's taught in in tech they take books
don't do that
that's bad okay so I mean we always got
a you know some option that controls
this yes yeah I mean we do it's called
[Music]
if you if you make that window
sufficiently narrow you'll see that fire
[Music]
[Music]
option options a section multi-line
function yes so what what do you think
so that you can set multi-line function
basically I think you can make it
always use a slab and certainly once it
becomes narrow it's going to this once
that window becomes known else that
action should split into in
right
well our live stream is commenting that
tech looks better for multi line format
the problem with the problem is yeah
sure if you type it in by hand it'll
look better that's not the problem we're
solving problem we're solving us we have
to deal with with machine generated
stuff um you know if you're prepared to
hand line-break things you can get you
know well I don't know how you know
that's a that seems like one of those
quintessential machine learning type
problems to be able to figure out how to
do this well um I mean that's an
interesting question whether which we've
never looked at is whether one could use
you know what are the things that make
hand typeset math look better and how
can we learn them I think it goes well
beyond I don't want to bring it up here
because it's something we were working
on so okay um all right fair enough
um okay I think we this this probably
the the conclusion of this meeting is we
should talk to Jason find out what
happened with the the tweaks that were
suggested before there is a whole
separate discussion I mean let's let's
wait for the tech tech in inline text
[Music]
functionality for the cloud that should
be coming I think in in version 1.50 um
or maybe 1.51 see how that works and
take this from there and I think this is
what there's a meeting that was long
scheduled or long in the scheduling
pipeline and yeah anybody have any
further comments nope
okay all right back to other things
thanks all thanks to the folks on the
live stream bye